NOW.
>> Sean: DEEP STATE IS BEING
EXPOSED.
MUELLER'S WITCH HUNT IS CRASHING
IN.
FASCINATING TIMES.
JOINING US, KIMBERLY STRASSEL.
SHE WAS THE FIRST JOURNALIST TO
EXPOSE THIS HUGE SCANDAL NEARLY
TWO WEEKS AGO.
SHE JOINS US AS WELL AS FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JASON CHAFFETZ.
I LOVE THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
AND THEIR COMMENTS, THEIR
EDITORIAL, KIMBERLY.
I THOUGHT IT WAS DEVASTATING AND
THE CALLS ON THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WHAT DID HE KNOW
AND WHEN DID HE KNEW IT.
AND NOW NUNES SAYS THERE MIGHT
BE A SECOND SPY?
>> THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE TO REMEMBER.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, WHICH
IS NOW OUT THERE HINTING AND
VARIOUS PARTISANS LIKE ADAM
SCHIFF THAT SOMEHOW CONGRESSMAN
NUNES AND OTHERS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR BLOWING THIS SOURCE?
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE LEAKED
ALL OF THESE DETAILS TO FRIENDLY
NEWS MEDIA SOURCES.
EVERYTHING SORT OF THIS GUY'S
NAME AND HIS SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER.
>> Sean: BINGO.
>> JUST SO THEY COULD GET AHEAD
OF THIS AND SPIN IT THE WAY THEY
WANTED TO BECAUSE THEY KNEW THE
NUESE WAS TIGHTENING AND
PROBABLY BE FORCED TO PUT OUT
THE DOCUMENTS.
THIS IS THE OTHER IMPORTANT
PART, TOO.
NONE OF US HAVE HAD ENOUGH
INFORMATION ON YET IS WE KNOW A
LOT ABOUT WHAT THE FBI DID,
ALTHOUGH STILL NOT ENOUGH, WHAT
WE DON'T KNOW IS WHAT THE
POLITICAL SIDE OF THIS OPERATION
KNEW.
WE KNOW CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN HAD
THIS DOSSIER, TOO.
WHO ELSE HAD IT IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION?
WHAT OTHER AGENCIES WERE
INVOLVED IN EFFORTS TO GO AFTER
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN PRIOR TO THE
FBI'S CLAIM OF ITS OFFICIAL
START OF THE INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: I'LL SAY IT.
I DON'T WANT TO BRING FORMER
CONGRESSMAN CHAFFETZ, SCHIFF IS
THE BIGGEST LIAR.
BIGGER POINTS HERE.
THE FBI PAID THIS GUY.
WE'VE KNOWN HIS NAME FOR A LONG
TIME, THIS IS NOT -- THEY LEAKED
IT.
THEY DID IT.
BUT PAYING THIS GUY MONEY AND
MAYBE A SECOND SPY?
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THEY'RE
GOING TO HAND OVER THE DOCUMENTS
IF THEY CAN GET AWAY WITH IT.
CONGRESSMAN CHAFFETZ, YOU
REQUESTED THE SAME INFORMATION
WELL OVER A YEAR AGO.
IT'S NEVER BEEN FORTHCOMING.
>> YEAH, THERE'S A SUBPOENA
ISSUED IN 2016 FOR ALL THE
DOCUMENTS THAT WE WANTED TO SEE.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL CAN GET
THESE DOCUMENTS IF HE HASN'T
ALREADY.
I HOPE HE'S GATHERED THEM UP.
I THINK THE DEEP STATE IS
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE TRUTH IS
GOING TO SURFACE AND THAT'S WHY
THEY'RE LEAKING THIS INFORMATION
TO FRIENDLY NEWS SOURCES TO PUT
THEIR OWN SPIN ON IT.
KIM STRASSEL HAS DONE THE BEST
REPORTING ON THAT.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, YOU HAVE A
ATTORNEY GENERAL WITH JEFF
SESSIONS WHO IS THERE IN NAME
ONLY.
HE'S WORTHLESS.
YOU HAVE ROD ROSENSTEIN WHO IS
THERE WITH AN OXYGEN MASK.
HE'S TOTALLY CONFLICTED.
I'M EXCITE HAD WITH SOME MEMBERS
IN THE HOUSE WILL DO TOMORROW.
I THINK THERE'S A GROUP OF FIVE
MEMBERS THAT WILL PUT FORWARD A
RESOLUTION THAT THEY NEED A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> I HEAR THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN
HAS A VICIOUS TEMPER AND IS
SCREAMING AT PEOPLE EVERY DAY.
IS YOU HEARD THAT?
>> IT'S NOT PRETTY OVER THERE.
AND YOU LOOK AT THE DEMOCRATS
LIKE ADAM SCHIFF, THIS POLITICAL
HACK THAT IS SO DESPERATE NOT TO
HAVE THE TRUTH TO COME OUT.
HE DOESN'T WANT IT.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO EXPOSE WHAT'S
GOING ON.
DEVIN NUNES IS PART OF THE GANG
OF EIGHT.
HE CAN LOOK AT THAT INFORMATION.
>> Sean: AND I AGREE WITH
CONGRESSMAN CHAFFETZ.
KIMBERLY, LAST WORD.
>> THIS HAS TO BE DECLASSIFIED.
CONGRESS NEEDS TO SEE IT FIRST
AND THEN WE ALL NEED TO SEE IT.
>> THE PRESIDENT CAN DO IT.
>> YES.
>> Sean: AND HE CAN DEMAND THEY
TURN THEM OVER NOW,
>> YEP.
>> YES.
>> HE'S THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THE ONLY CONSTITUTIONALLY
ELECTED PERSON AND HE CAN
DECLASSIFY IT.
>> Sean: NOW.
I'D SAY THE PRESIDENT, DO IT
NOW.
DO NOT WASTE 18 MONTHS FOR THE
I.G. TO INVESTIGATE WITH 500